sir Roger Gale is with us now hello to
you sir Roger thank you for joining us
on the program this morning could you
have predicted any of this
no
quite simply
um because I I didn't see it coming in
this way
um I I said after the mini budget The
Fortunes favored the brave but not the
foolhardy and I felt at the time that
that was full Hardy but that at least I
suppose has been proved right but the
rest of it no I don't think many people
predicted how this was going to play out
or is playing out
uh what do you think uh Jeremy Hunt is
up to
I think Jeremy Hunt has taken on the job
it's quite clear that he's taken on the
job on his terms that he said he will do
it but he'll only do it if he can do
what he believes to be necessary to
stabilize the markets to stabilize the
economy
and to get the show back on track and
that's what he's doing and there is real
power in Downing Street but it's not in
number 10 it's in number 11.
why is he having why is he announcing
another statement today why is he not
waiting going through the books working
with the Prime Minister and waiting
until the 31st of October which is a
date which has already been brought
forward for another look at this prime
minister's fiscal plans
what I think the chancellor is seeking
to do is to stabilize the markets pure
and simple at this stage that um longer
term plan will be announced on the 31st
of October as I understand it and that
will be make or break both for the new
Chancellor and also for the Prime
Minister if if she's still in post at
that time and I have to say that
because it may be that she will review
her own position but look okay what I'm
concerned about and what I think we all
be concerned about is the fact that this
is real people's real lives real Homes
real small businesses that are at stake
this is not or shouldn't be about the
conservative party but about the future
of the country and the economy and I
genuinely think that that is what Jeremy
Hunt is seeking to address we've got to
keep the market stable to allow
ourselves time to get through this and
to come out hopefully On the Sunny Side
so Roger how has your party got itself
in this mess
oh well apparently with considerable eat
um
I I
um it's no secret I I did not vote for
Mrs truss and just for the record I
didn't vote for Rishi sunak either uh in
the final ballot I felt that I'd had my
say and others had to have their set in
the party
chose Mrs trust she came forward with a
plan which was bold and brave but as
I've said I think foolhardy she didn't
she's acknowledged it she didn't
roll the pitch she didn't prepare the
ground
and her Chancellor didn't prepare the
ground so
everybody was caught I think to a large
extent on the Hop and the markets don't
like that that's led to a situation that
is I'm afraid of a financial situation
that yes it's heavily influenced by
global Affairs but also
is very much of our own making
do you agree with what she was trying to
achieve
I think we could probably certainly on
our side of the house all agree with
what she was trying to achieve in the
sense that we are and want to be a low
tax party and we are and historically
have been and want to be
in support of growth the economy has
been flatlining for far too long
what she's sought to do
was to stimulate growth in a very big
way indeed
but in order to do that she took some
measures that quite clearly were not
palatable not acceptable either to the
public or to the markets and that has
been what may well prove to be her done
for
but what she said she was trying to do
along with her previous chancellor who
can say that after 38 days was to
stimulate the economy in order to try
and get growth of two and a half percent
that's not going to happen is it now
well whether that happens or not will
depend upon what this Chancellor does
and how he does it I obviously hope that
he'll succeed in stimulating that growth
but what she did and what her Chancellor
at the time did what quasi-quarting did
was to make significant Cuts in tax
unfunded and that's what spooked
everybody where is the money coming from
she had already quite rightly
and correctly sought to bail out
People's Energy bills for not only for
this winter we have to remember which is
what the labor party were talking about
doing but for two years at very
considerable cost that was the right
thing to do what she should have done in
my view is to have stopped there
quarter breath looked at the whole scene
and then come forward with a properly
prepared proposal
what actually happened was that the mini
budget was rushed out
without sufficient preparation without
sufficient thought and without
sufficient explanation That's What's led
to the downfall of her first Chancellor
and may well lead I feared to her
downfall
as we know Mr Roger MPS did not want her
to be the next prime minister as you
said quite rightly they wanted it to be
Richie sooner but the members did
were the members wrong
I think
members of parliament probably have a
better perspective of both the economic
situation and the personalities than the
general membership for very good reason
we know them we work with them day by
day
the general membership doesn't and and
that's understandable and I don't think
we should expect I'm not seeking to
blame the membership for getting it
wrong
it was not my choice but I we have to
accept we live in a democracy we accept
the system as it is but look again the
situation we face now unfortunately is a
lot of people apparently although I
don't rely on newspapers for saying how
many letters have gone into Graham Brady
and those letters at the moment aren't
worth the paper they're written on
because the rules would have to be
changed in order to have a leadership
election and God knows the last thing we
want is another leadership election
he then got the situation where if the
Prime Minister were to decide that her
position was untenable
and she went
then there will have to be I think a
coronation now in order for that to
happen
you've got to have an agreed candidate
and at the moment I see no single agreed
candidate within the party
could there not be a coalition of the
sides
um we know that Rishi sunak and Penny
mordant despite them saying they're not
they are both clearly on maneuvers
well um Penny Walden has been saying and
she's absolutely right to say that what
we need at the moment is stability and
that is what Jeremy Hunt is trying to
inject I think into the situation I said
earlier and I will say again that
the power in Downey street is in number
11 not number 10. I think Jeremy Hunt is
de facto prime minister at the moment
and I hope that he will be able to he's
a very experienced man he's had long
experience in cabinets he's been foreign
secretary as well as the health
secretary
he's a businessman a self-made
businessman he understands economics and
I think he can get this right but it's
quite clear
that all the shots are now being called
from number 11 and in a way I have to
say I'm very pleased that they are
because I think that will stabilize the
markets and I hope that we can find a
way forward for the United Kingdom for
our country not for the conservative
party
is that because uh Jeremy Hunter is
prime ministerial and the Prime Minister
doesn't know what she's doing
I think Jeremy Hunt does know what he's
doing and I'm not going to seek to take
side swipes that anybody else at all I
just think that we've got now
the right man in the job at the time
people rise to occasions and I think
that I hope that Jeremy will I wish him
well in his Endeavors for the sake of
the country because if he gets this
wrong then we're going to go to hell in
a Hancock but if we get it right then we
can emerge from this I think better and
stronger and we can start to move
forward in the direction that we all
really want to go
would he be a good prime minister
well
I supported him
for the Premiership when he stood
against Boris Johnson so not
surprisingly I would have to say
absolutely yes to that
but that's not the game that he appears
to be in he's doing a job he's getting
on with the job I hope and I I think and
everything that's coming out of number
11 suggests that he's working very hard
and very fast
do men's and fences so let's let him get
on and do the job
and take each step I think as it comes
I'll be very interested to see what he
says from the treasury later this
morning
uh just a reflection Before I Let You Go
um the prime minister's news conference
on Friday how did you react to that I'm
sure you were watching it either live or
caught it soon after
it was commendably brief
I think I was interested to note that
the four journalists who were allowed to
ask questions didn't ask the one
question but I and I suspect by a lot of
other people wanted asked which was
given that you are joined at the hip
with your Chancellor given that you all
believe you both believe in the same
policies given that you prepared the
mini budget together why have you sacked
him
nobody answered that question
but nobody else
yeah to be fair she didn't take many
questions though did she
no but I would for me if I if I've been
one of those journalists present if I'd
been Harry Cole for example and given
the opportunity to ask the question
that's the question that I'd have asked
first
how do you expect Before I Let You Go
final question how do you expect today
to pan out
this is the final final question is that
I didn't mind in the slices I'm very
happy to talk yeah yeah well unless I
think of another one
I think what will happen I hope what
will happen is that Jeremy Hunt will
come forward
with some quick measures to stabilize
the markets to give the markets the
confidence that we need before the
markets open today which
um as uh as your political correspondent
said quite correctly why the statement
is being made from the treasury and not
in the House of Commons as normally and
courteously it would be and as the
speaker no doubt would like it but
because it's Monday because the house is
sitting at 2 30 not at 11 30 and the
markets will be open but your chance of
exchequer clearly wants to make his
pitch now in order to tell the markets
that the country's in safe hands and I
hope that they will accept that